[Music]
as covet 19 sucks up medical resources
people with hiv feel deprived of care
on world aids day activists say a
prolonged pandemic is deepening the
inequalities that have long driven the
hiv epidemic
the medical care the financing in the
hiv sector
all that no longer exists
what needs to be done to fight both
covet 19 and hiv
welcome to your covenant 19 special i'm
chris colbert berlin while much of the
world has been focusing on the
coronavirus pandemic the un is warning
on this world aids day that the fight
against covet 19 is seriously impeding
global efforts of ending
the disease by 2030 and those affected
are still subjected to stigma and
discrimination
frank
is hiv positive but with the treatment
available today he can lead a healthy
life
nevertheless his diagnosis in 2016 came
as a shock
my only thought was i'm going to die
even though hiv is all around us i never
thought i would be affected
thoughts no longer revolve around death
today's medication keeps him healthy but
he suffers from the stigma of prejudice
and exclusion
in the 1970s a virus was discovered
which is thought to have been
transmitted from monkeys to humans
over time it attacks and destroys the
immune system
panic spread across the world fueled by
the lack of aids awareness
in 1991 queen's lead singer freddie
mercury died of aids
a year later a tribute concert watched
by some 70 million people worldwide was
held in london
it was then that the new york-based
visual aids artist caucus made the red
ribbon the universal symbol of awareness
german for advice and action is the name
of this drop-in support center run by
the german aid service organization
frank shep got counseling here after his
positive hiv test
yet even today the organization's
counselors hear many stories about
discrimination
they've been mentioning people lose
their jobs because the name of a doctor
known to specialize in hiv is on their
medical certificate
they get asked why are you going to that
doctor
and they get fired
frank
pays regular visits to his doctor
so the effectiveness of his medication
can be monitored
thanks to medical advancements people
with hiv can now lead normal lives
of the people who are diagnosed these
days and receive antiretroviral therapy
that is hiv treatment over 95 percent
have a viral load below the detection
limit
when the load is at an undetectable
level they can't transmit it to another
person
i don't think people are generally aware
of this even doctors who work in
hospitals
there's a lot of discrimination against
people with hiv in the health care
system too
frank
wants to help fight prejudice and
educate people
he also founded a self-help group
no one should be afraid of people who
are hiv positive
because with the kind of treatment that
he receives
transmitting the virus to others is
impossible
you can live a normal life with hiv just
like frank chap
earlier i spoke to nigel garrett head of
vaccines and pathogenesis research at
the center
for the aids program of research in
south africa and i asked him if he
agreed with anthony fauci the u.s top
infectious disease expert who says that
the pandemic has diverted
scientific and financial resources from
the fight against aids
yeah i think that's certainly true uh
chris we we've seen it in uh in our
setting where i work in kwazulu-natal
in south africa where
uh the the number of tests being done on
people has reduced dramatically by about
50 percent
uh about half the people only started on
antiretroviral treatment which is
obviously vital for survival if you have
hiv
and then also on the research front uh
most of the research funding was now
channeled into cope uh into corbett
research and uh obviously accelerating
the vaccine pipeline in in
for sasko v2 so
i think overall um you know basically
the attention of all policy makers has
shifted to some degree to
to covet but we i think we're also
learning a lot about
obviously vaccines and possibilities
that we can back translate to hiv
hopefully once we've got this
pandemic under control
now
several case reports suggest that some
virus variants including omicron that
everybody's talking about now may have
evolved in
immunocompromised people potentially
hiv patients can you explain why
yeah so there have been two or three
case reports
one in the uk where they followed
someone who was on chemotherapy and
severely immunocompromised
and they just found persistent shedding
of of the virus
which then means that the immune
response is still there but it's it's
not able to clear the virus
which then allows the virus to mutate
in in a in a single human being
and a similar case was
also found in in south africa in an
hiv-positive patient who had a very low
immune system
uh not on antiretroviral treatment
and
they found that
this particular person developed three
or four
mutations
over a certain amount of months so
probably about a year
so my hypothesis is that this is kind of
a
what they call a reservoir for for
variant evolution
and i think we need to do a lot more
research
which larger implications would this
then have if there was a
link between the omicron variant and
hiv patients or immunocompromised
patients
yeah i think basically we need to push
vaccinations to everyone and
in a lot of countries now the us
uk and i think germany as well have
implemented a third booster dose for um
as part of the primary vaccination dose
uh for immunocompromised
patients
so i think that's that's crucial that we
keep pushing vaccinations and then
obviously for hiv specifically we need
to ensure that we test as many people as
possible and start people on treatment
to improve their immune system so that
we can avoid this phenomenon from
happening
why is hiv so much harder to fight
than covet 19.
um well there it's it's a very different
virus so there are many reasons some of
them are
biological of course and then some of
them are maybe more behavioral so hiv is
a chronic infection once you infect it
you
it stays with you
so often people are what we call
asymptomatic and they don't know that
they're infected
and then continue to infect
especially if they're not on treatment
and suppress from in terms of their
viral load
and then also there are some more
structural issues like stigma and
discrimination still
hiv is predominantly sexually
transmitted infection
so surrounding that you get a lot of
stigma evolving and then
obviously that does not help in terms of
the prevention effort and also the
treatment effort
and nigel if we focus on the medical
aspect aspect here um we spoke back in
june and what has changed since then
where does the field stand today
regarding a potential vaccination
against hiv
yeah so we had some exciting new
findings the uh i think i mentioned it
in june the imbecoda trial which was the
r26 so that's the
johnson johnson platform that's also
used in covet
they developed a mosaic vaccine
we have now got the results of that it
showed a 25 reduction in hiv
transmissions
unfortunately not enough of an effect to
show
statistical
significance but enough to do correlate
analyses so we we will be looking at you
know what potentially protected some of
the population
um
so that was one and then there's a
larger trial that is still ongoing in
the us and
south america in
[Music]
msm so menu of sex with men and
transgender people and we're hoping to
learn more about this concept
and then also the
amp studies so this antibody mediated
prevention trial was also presented this
year
and found that
these antibodies uh broadly neutralizing
antibodies essentially can
prevent infection with a sensitive virus
but not a resistant virus
so that is
where we are now heading with the field
in terms of giving combination antibody
bodies for prevention
nigel garrett of the center for the aids
program of research in south africa or
caprisun nigel thank you
thank you thanks for having me
the newly detected coronavirus variant
is also the topic of one of your
questions for our science correspondent
daryl williams
what do we know so far about the omicron
variant
both a lot and still very little a lot
because we already know a lot about sars
kovi ii and
although this variant has a long list of
mutations compared to earlier versions
of the virus
experts keep emphasizing that it isn't a
completely different pathogen it's the
old one with some new characteristics
and there are are three characteristics
in particular that are really
interesting for us first is
does it spread faster than other
variants
second is does it make you sicker than
other variants and third is
can it get around your immune defenses
easily even if you've been vaccinated
or recovered
it'll take weeks to accumulate enough
data to move
beyond speculation for any of those
three questions but but some early
indicators are leading some scientists
to make
educated guesses
for example um early data from the
variants spread in south africa where
omicron was initially identified
indicates that it could indeed be pretty
transmissible though
just how it stacks up to delta for
instance remains to be seen if it is
though the reasons will lie in its
genetic code scientists have detected
dozens
of new mutations in the rna
that encodes for omicron's spike protein
which is shown in pink in this picture
it's the key that the virus uses
to break into cells so
if the new variant does prove highly
transmissible the reason will likely lie
there
other mutations have led some
researchers to think that omicron could
also be better at getting around
immunity so
this might end up being the first
variant where we have to tailor
messenger rna vaccines but we'll only
know that in a couple of weeks on the
positive side
a few doctors in south africa have said
that patient symptoms and outbreaks
there
have remained mostly mild
especially in people who were vaccinated
but that's just anecdotal evidence from
a country with a young population and
and only studies that are racing ahead
now
will provide more hard data on whether
or not the variant
actually is more or less deadly so
watch the space i'm i'm sure i'm going
to be talking about omicron
plenty in the weeks to come
that's our show thanks for watching stay
safe
[Music]
you